[Musique]
ici dans le parc naturel régional du
Perche je me balade entre deux régions
qui se partagent ce joyau naturel et
humain
du Centre-Val de Loire à la Normandie
l'identité percherone est très présente
avec la sauvegarde de ses ressources
naturelles ces paysages colinéens ces
forêts ces oiseaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vraiment un oiseau ça ça c'est
le cri d'un médiateur du patrimoine on
est d'accord que ici nous sommes dans le
domaine du manoir de Courboyer qui fait
partie du Parc naturel régional du
Perche entre la Normandie et le centre
Val de Loire et c'est un endroit où on
reçoit du public et où on peut faire
valoir l'entièreté des richesses que
l'on trouve sur le territoire donc les
richesses naturelles les richesses
bâties tu parles de milieu naturel on
trouve quoi ici en faune et en flore ce
qui est le plus représentatif de la
partie centrale du Perche c'est une
structure paysagère qu'on appelle le
bocage en plus du bocage sur lequel se
trouve la maison du parc on va trouver
un étang comme celui qui est là on
trouve aussi quelques forêts on va
trouver des vergers et on va trouver
aussi des marres donc en fait l'ensemble
donne une image assez représentative de
ce qu'on peut considérer comme étant le
Perche d'un point de vue paysager ben
écoute on va visiter tout seul
encore du boulot
nous allons peut-être essayer tous les
deux d'entrer en contact avec un oiseau
qui n'est pas un oiseau d'urne qui est
plutôt un oiseau nocturne et peut-être
aurons-nous une réponse alors presque
c'est une chouette
alors on peut essayer de s'installer ici
alors je ne te garantis pas qu'elle va
se manifester mais quand tu veux une
chouette au défi en imitant le cri d'un
autre mâle sur son propre territoire et
bien pour ne pas perdre ce territoire
elle peut répondre pour affirmer la
possession de ce territoire Jean-Pierre
est là la chouette manifeste toi c'est
le meilleur moyen
pour faire capoter l'affaire c'est on
pouvait pas faire mieux alors on essaye
de sommeil profond si tu veux peut-être
que c'est pour ça qu'elle ne répond pas
et bien en attendant l'apparition
providentielle de la chouette je vous
propose de regarder le nouveau single le
nouveau clip de Jean-Pierre featuring
Kamini wings of chouette
[Musique]
on verra on attend la chouette
maintenant
je crois que j'ai compris la technique
ça glisse comme ça
c'est très bien alléluia